to be honest  white is totally helpless against this  threat  rook takes knight as well there's just  rook takes knight as well is  queen in the corner this does  just yeah there's so many so many moves  here right the white king has finally  met its match yeah it's just nowhere to  hide  three attacking black pieces and white's  piece is just not coordinated enough to  defend the king can't run can it because  you can just then take the rook so at  the very least yeah you take the rook  and then you're gonna be up on material  soon i mean  poor olive you can see his body language  yeah i mean  this is a  a brilliant game um absolutely  fantastic game you know relax against  the youngsters they just always have  another trick hidden up their sleeve and  do you would you be tempted to go rook  takes night and yeah it's on the board  and  just resigns oh  he does shaking the hand of pragnanda  who wins another match against another  clan